I'll just start with a simple page,
that has three divs,
contained within a container div.
In normal block layout,
each div is positioned,
one underneath the other one.
But once I add display
flex to the container div,
the divs, are now shown in a row.
That's because the default
flex direction, is row.
By default,
flex items fit on a single line.
So no matter what I set the width of
the elements to be, they won't wrap.
Instead, the browser will size
them to fit within the viewport.
I can change that, by adding flex-wrap:
wrap; to the container element.
That tells the browser,
that it's okay for
the elements inside to
wrap to the next line.
Now, as I resize the viewport,
instead of resizing elements,
it wraps the first element.
And then,
only resizes when it really needs to.
So far, we've only looked at two
properties of the flex container.
There are several others
worth looking at.